[Music]
on this sunday night the start of a long
goodbye
queen elizabeth coffin starts the
journey to london i want to thank the
queen for
everything she's done for us the crowds
turning out to see her funeral cortege
as it traveled through scotland our
interview with canada's high
commissioner to the uk you've just come
back from the palace you met the new
king for the first time what was that
like what the royal transition means for
canada and a runaway victory for
pierre-palieve what you see is what you
get there were a lot of canadians that
supported the convoy why the new
conservative leader is pledging not to
pivot to the center
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight from london
the beginning of her final journey queen
elizabeth ii's coffin leaving what's
widely known to be her favorite place
balmoral castle in the scottish
highlands making a six-hour journey to
edinburgh thousands of mourners lining
the route even along rural roads in
scotland and then crowding into the city
to pay their respects
princess anne the queen's only daughter
traveled with the funeral cortege and as
her mother's coffin was carried by
pallbearers into the palace of hollyrood
house she curtsied maintaining royal
protocol even in grief
and outside buckingham palace in london
and windsor castle people keep coming
people of all ages many carrying flowers
and other tributes to the queen they're
taking the time to say farewell to the
only monarch most of them have ever
known to be part of an historic moment
good evening from london three days
after her death this country has begun
to formally say goodbye to queen
elizabeth her coffin will remain in
edinburgh for people to pay their
respects there before it's flown here to
london the size of the crowds turning up
already and the volume of flowers gives
you some sense of how many want to pay
tribute to her our europe bureau chief
crystal gamansing has been watching the
funeral cortege and the reaction crystal
donna in just over a week's time
dignitaries from around the world will
be here at westminster abbey to attend a
state funeral but today it was regular
people in cities and towns around
scotland who were paying their respects
and they came out by the thousands
the royal standard of scotland covering
her majesty's oak coffin the first
sightings bringing home the reality of
the queen's death she's been loyal she's
been dignified she's been kind and
compassionate
ballader is just a few minutes away from
balmoral castle people in this town felt
close to the queen
and not just because of the proximity
it's been such an incredibly sad week
knowing the queen has passed
some along the procession route saddled
up knowing how much the queen loved
horses a wartime mechanic said to have
been able to drive any vehicle she may
have also delighted in some bringing
their tractors
princess anne in the procession of royal
vehicles making the drive from balmoral
to edinburgh with her mother one final
time
among those lining the root and leaving
gifts young children many just getting
to know the woman with the jewels and
handbag we was going to put the flower
stain
and who the flowers formed
we want to thank the queen for
everything she's done for us
and we've laid some flowers put flowers
down and
yeah just want to show our
gratefulness to her the six hour journey
by car allowed tens of thousands of
people from across scotland the
opportunity to honor the queen
without having to travel to england her
death at balmoral castle on september
8th triggered an alternative set of
plans which the queen herself helped to
craft and included a night at the royal
scottish residence the palace of
hollywood house we felt we just had to
come
and pay with respect to the queen
the royal mile leading to hollywood
house packed with people ushering the
coffin carrying the queen
into the protective gates in the palace
that has sheltered royals going back
more than 500 years
monday afternoon there will be another
procession as the queen's coffin is
moved to st giles cathedral king charles
iii and the queen consort camilla will
follow by foot
there the coffin will lay in rest for 24
hours giving more people in scotland the
opportunity to pay their respects
donna
crystal command saying thanks the
queen's funeral will be held at
westminster abbey behind me and we will
bring you live coverage of the funeral
on monday september 19th
a busy day for the new king with a
string of formal meetings and
introductions with representatives from
across the commonwealth today
thousands of people lined the road to
buckingham palace cheering and waving as
king charles iii was driven by the king
was followed by his wife camilla the
queen consort who traveled in a separate
vehicle king charles held a series of
meetings today with the uk's foreign
secretary the commonwealth general
secretary and representatives from
across the commonwealth including
canada's high commissioner to the uk
i'll have an interview with ralph
goodale coming up just a little bit
later
the prime minister of the caribbean
nation of antigua and barbuda says he'll
call for a referendum on removing king
charles as head of state minutes after
signing a document confirming charles
the third's status as the new king
gaston brown said that in three years he
will push within three years he will
push for a referendum on becoming a
republic the caribbean country is one of
14 nations outside britain to retain
king charles as their head of state some
other countries have signaled their
intention to reconsider the role of the
monarchy too though australia's prime
minister today ruled out having a
referendum on the issue there within the
next four years
so what lies ahead for the monarchy in
canada well i had a chat with canada's
high commissioner to the uk just after
he came back from meeting the new king
at the palace that's coming up just a
little bit later first farah nasser in
toronto has the rest of the day's news
thanks donna coming up the conservatives
populist pick how the liberals are
hoping to use pierre polyev's right-wing
anti-establishment message against him
multiple fires are burning around b.c
and south of the border in oregon
washington and california filling the
air with a thick blanket of smoke two
fires are burning in the fraser valley
just east of metro vancouver while an
evacuation order has been issued for the
town of hudson's hope in northeastern
b.c an air quality advisory is in place
for the fraser valley and vancouver
where the smoke is so thick that the
city's air quality was ranked the worst
in the world today that's according to
the world air quality index
last night pierre paulieb was voted in
as the new leader of his majesty's loyal
opposition paliev ran a right-wing
populist campaign centered on freedom
and won the conservative leadership
contest in convincing fashion with 68
percent on the first ballot but as our
chief political correspondent david
aiken reports the very message that won
pauliev so much support
is the very message his opponents will
be trying to use against him
tonight begins the journey to replace an
old government that costs you more and
delivers you less with a new government
that puts you first among the 338
ridings in the country pierre poliev won
all but eight he won the support of red
tories libertarians free marketers
social conservatives every faction in
his party came to his flag now today we
are one party serving one country
he won with a campaign that raged
against what he called the country's
elites elites at the bank of canada in
the mainstream media in public health
labs but most of all in the trudeau
government i think the liberals are
probably a little worried this is a
united conservative movement and it's a
movement that has obviously grown
pauliev has done a very good job of
bringing in new people to the party we
will restore canada's promise in a
country where it doesn't matter who you
love or if your name is smith or singh
martin or muhammad chang or charles and
while prime minister justin trudeau did
call pauliev saturday night to
congratulate him liberals were quick to
say pauliev is not a uniter but a
polarizing divider mr paliev
chooses to take a different approach or
to be a divisive polarizing figure and
try and paralyze
parliament we don't think canadians will
be impressed or warned to that approach
liberals say polyeth's support for last
winter's freedom convoy in ottawa is a
flaw but pauliev supporters say no
that's not a bug it's a feature i think
with pierre what you see is what you
what you get there were a lot of
canadians that that supported the uh
support of the convoy in uh and and if
not specifically the convoy
the ideals that they uh what they
espoused in terms of uh being against
lockdowns pauliev will get right to work
the new leader of his majesty's loyal
opposition will meet with his 119 mp
caucus monday morning pharah
david aiken in ottawa thank you david
in saskatchewan the first funerals are
underway for victims of last weekend's
mass stabbing on the james smith cree
nation and the community of weldon but
there is anything but closure there as
the police investigation continues there
are now calls for a public inquiry into
the tragedy with many questions on how
it all unfolded and why mike armstrong
has more
it appeared to be almost a painful
admission for police
just hours after suspect miles sanderson
died in police custody the head of the
saskatchewan rcmp said even though more
than 100 officers are working on the
case sanderson's death likely means the
attacks and the reason for them may
never be fully understood unfortunately
you know
now that miles is deceased we may never
have an understanding of that motivation
now the other thing sanderson's death
means is there won't be a trial that
would have meant evidence and testimony
a degree of transparency that may have
helped the public deal with what
happened
in the absence of a criminal trial legal
expert archie kaiser says the tragedy
has some parallels to the 2020
port-a-pick tragedy in nova scotia both
were unfathomable in terms of the loss
of life and in both cases the
perpetrators were killed there was no
trial the nova scotia government
resisted an inquiry at first but is now
holding a mass casualty commission
saskatchewan kaiser says should consider
something similar it's difficult to see
how there can be a full examination
of
all of the events
and the things that led to them without
a proper public inquiry there are
multiple investigations and reviews
underway into different aspects of what
happened in saskatchewan and what led to
it police are looking at the attacks the
parole board is reviewing the decision
to grant sanderson's statutory release
letting him out of prison early and
sanderson's death while in rcmp custody
is being looked at by the saskatoon
police service and a civilian-led
organization the serious incident
response team was only recently created
as oversight on crimes involving police
it is quite new only just about a year
old
this will be very much almost an acid
case for this new body to prove to the
public that it has got the ability to do
these things independently without
police interference
one of the big issues that led to the
port of pick inquiry was the police
response during that attack there hasn't
been as much criticism in the
saskatchewan case with observers saying
the rcmp seemed to have learned from
their mistakes we're hearing lots of
information about what happened the head
of the canadian prison law association
says a broad and expensive inquiry isn't
needed instead tom engel wants a focused
look at the lack of support sanderson
appears to have gotten in prison and on
parole
correctional services canada he says
isn't doing enough for rehabilitation
this is a serious problem
and we probably won't get to the root of
that problem
without a public inquiry now engel does
say transparency may be an issue in
those reviews police forces in canada he
says are reluctant to release things
like dash cam videos that may help the
public better understand what happened
in the u.s he says the dash cam videos
from the cruisers in sanderson's arrest
likely would have already been released
instead in canada the public will likely
never see them
mike armstrong global news regina
and there is some help for those
struggling from the tragedy and want to
reach out you can call the hope for
wellness helpline or crisis services
canada at the numbers on your screen
ahead turning point in the war russian
forces flee a strategic city allowing
ukraine's army to make giant gains
russia's response next
to ukraine now where a multi-pronged
counter-offensive by ukrainian forces is
swiftly taking back large chunks of
territory from russian occupiers
in a saturday address president vladimir
zelinsky says russia's army is showing
its back as ukraine makes rapid progress
reclaiming towns and cities in the
kharkiv region its military says it has
recaptured some 3 000 square kilometers
meanwhile despite much evidence of
equipment and weapons being left behind
in what appears to be a quick retreat
officials in moscow claim their
withdrawal was planned
the last reactor of europe's largest
nuclear plant in ukraine has now been
shut off to avert disaster while
fighting continues nearby shelling cut
off the zaparisia plant from the power
grid last week raising fears of a
possible meltdown with its cooling
systems relying only on emergency power
but late saturday it managed to
reconnect just long enough to initiate a
shutdown the plant's operators say this
is the safest state as the ongoing
conflict makes it too risky to operate
international aid is finally trickling
into pakistan's flood-ravaged regions
today two more u.s military planes
arrived loaded with 35 tons of food and
first aid supplies months of deadly
monsoon rain has destroyed homes washed
away an entire year's crops and made
clean drinking water scarce the floods
have killed almost 1400 people it's
estimated 33 million more are now
displaced and dealing with hunger and
rising risk of water-borne diseases
and in the u.s poignant ceremonies were
held today as americans marched 21 years
since the 9 11 attacks
21 years ago
21 years and we still kept our promise
never forget
[Music]
president joe biden speaking at the
pentagon where one of the hijacked
planes killed nearly 200 people that day
of course there were also ceremonies in
new york to honor the victims of the
devastating world trade center attacks
nearly 3 000 people died in the terror
attacks in 2001.
next arriving directly from the palace
canada's high commissioner to the uk
discusses his meeting with the king
today we're back to london with donna
right after this short break
you're watching global national
welcome back to london canada's prime
minister the governor general and the
high commissioner to the uk ralph
goodale are invited to the queen's
funeral on september 19th there may be
others too the final guest list is still
being worked on i met mr goodell earlier
today on his way from meeting the new
king along with representatives from
other commonwealth countries
you've just come back from the palace
you met the new king for the first time
what was that like
well there was a
profound sense of history in the room so
the the king was there and the queen
consort
this event has never happened in the
last 70 years
one era turning to another era
a dominant personality much loved
in in queen elizabeth is gone
a new king has taken over so history is
changing and being a part of that change
of history
was one of the emotions in the room
another obviously was
was grief and mourning for
for queen elizabeth this is a big burden
for the new king charles to take on he's
lost his mother he's also taking on this
huge role
as you say from a woman who was so much
loved had so much respect
what sense did you get from him
personally today it's very personal he
has lost his mother anybody who's gone
through that experience knows how tough
that that is
you
you feel a bit orphaned
and of course he's lost both of his
parents in the course of the last year
and a bit yeah
so
it's got to be
unsettling disorienting and still
in the grieving process
he has to do it very much in public uh
the pressures
uh have to be enormous the stresses and
the strains
uh but
he certainly leaves you with the
impression that he is he is ready for
the job we talked a lot about uh
his recent visit to to canada he was
there in the spring a very busy agenda
and uh there were many components to it
but two in particular his connection
with the ukrainian diaspora in in canada
at this critical time and his
connections many of them uh with uh
indigenous communities
and
clearly there
uh i think he he he has a very real
sense of how important
truth reconciliation and healing is to
the future of canada
and
the role of the monarchy in particular
those treaties were signed with the
crown
not with any particular government with
the crown it's a special relationship a
very special relationship and now
it's him
and uh i i think
certainly he he gave me the impression
he understands that he is intensely
interested in it
and he wants to be helpful many people
say the monarchy will not be the same
without the queen
do you think
can you make the case for why
it continues to matter for canada if it
does continue to matter
well
undoubtedly
it will it will
not be the same as
the
the monarchy of elizabeth ii so when
that
powerful personality
moves aside and disappears from the
scene clearly things will change
but the
the
the issues i think canadians need to
look at is do we
do we really want to reopen
a constitutional hassle because it does
involve constitutional change is that a
productive
discussion to have
at a time where the existing apparatus
actually works pretty well
in terms of dealing with things that a
monarchy has to deal with
and if you're going to change
then
to what
what is the alternative that is going to
be
better
maybe the model in the united states
maybe not
mr goodell thank you so much pleasure
thank you
earlier today i took a walk through
green park to the mall that leads to
buckingham palace and there is a steady
stream of thousands of people many
bringing flowers even marmalade
sandwiches that's a nod to the skit the
queen did for the jubilee with
paddington bear so many people love that
there are messages like thank you for
everything rest in peace
and my favorite this card showing the
queen's corgis running from the gates of
heaven to greet her
that is global national for this sunday
i'm donna friesen thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you